the one business still booming in
afghanistan is transport
laden with exports from fruits to
minerals thousands of trucks can still
make their way through the narrow passes
and border crossings
even this has slowed since the taliban
took over
in previous years we were transporting
and going with our trucks eight to nine
trips a month but now we can only do
once a month there are no businessmen so
there's no one to hire us
more afghans are struggling to feed
their families than ever before after
four decades there is peace but people
are still waiting to benefit from it
the aid reliant economy collapsed when
funds were suspended and nine billion
dollars of afghan central bank's assets
were frozen the un appealed for 4.4
billion dollars in aid but barely half
of that has been pledged
hundreds of thousands of people have
lost their jobs an estimated 90 percent
of this population lives below the
poverty line but taliban leaders say
they are going to resurrect the economy
and are on target to make 2.5 billion
dollars this year
our
budget annually the ministry of finance
is challenging international
organizations to audit its claims that
the country is now corruption free
the
budget in target is completely dependent
on our own revenue resources
we have
generated about 800 million dollars from
customs
400 million dollars
from
non-tax revenues which mostly come from
mines
mining is an important part of
afghanistan's economy providing
employment to an estimated 1 million
people that includes not just the miners
themselves but also traders transporters
and exporters
there was always fighting that's why
there wasn't much consideration for
mines the islamic emirates started
operations in the mines ministry and in
one year we have realigned many pending
projects we will build a huge exchange
for afghan minerals in kabul for local
and international traders
that and much else still depends on the
taliban being recognized as
afghanistan's legitimate government
until then more afghans will have to buy
stale bread from this market with
promises about the future still mean
little
swamp with al jazeera kabul